Alcohol is really bad actually after the flight it's the worst
idea you can have because dehydrates you even more.
So there is really no point to drink even beer because there is
still this myth about beer that it hydrates you.
That's totally false. You had the calm of Roger
Federer, to say the least. That is what I saw on your face.
How do you process emotions when things have not gone as free of
lands? Yeah, you know, I throw a lot of
helmet in my life. So now I wasn't always like
this. It's one of the most tense
moments of my life, career I would say, because I know that
if I lose the zero, I lose the title.
So how do you think that OK, I want to become a better pilot?
What is your hard work looking like at this stage in your life?
It seems a bit weird to do this, but my.
Thank you for saying it so honestly.
It's very hard to be open about such things, but if more people
can realize that there is a limit.
Yeah, there is a limit because yeah, yeah, some cool talks with
people thinking that when you do the exalt then after you can fly
in any condition. That's really false.
Like it's untrue. Our park riders have limits, the
pilots have limits. So at some point there is no
point to fly in some condition with with this fucking park
riders. What is up everyone?
Welcome back to your weekly dose of awesomeness here at
Paragliding Apple's podcast. I'm your host, Aninder Singh,
and we are coming to you definitely live, but still
exclusively from the racing capital of the world, the
Macedonian town of Crocevo, where we came for the
Paragliding World Cup 2025 edition.
And with me today, we have a guest that has influenced our
style of flying at some place or the other and is somebody that a
lot of us look forward to whenever he takes to the skies.
Maxine Bill, this has been a long time coming.
I had an absolute honour to have you on the show, Sir.
Hello everyone thing. Max, I want to start by a little
bit of history, if you may. You have been flying for quite a
while. So how did power lighting come
into your life, and what were the early beginnings like?
Yeah, I came quite early with my father.
I did my first time in flight when I was something like 7 or 8
and and more and more between 9:00 to 12:00.
And a lot of ground ending at this moment because I had a
little hall wing and I was around handling a lot.
And I started playing alone when I was 13 years old.
And from there the, yeah, the journey begins 13 So that's like
just early teens. Did you have some sort of
fascination with flying or what was your attraction which kept
you going when there was early years?
At the beginning my father was flying, I remember, but I wasn't
going with him because I was doing also all the sport, like
at the beginning, tennis, judo. My sister is in the French,
French team of judo also. And then when I went one time
looking to my father flying and I said, oh, looks fun.
When did the idea of doing this full time come to you in your
life? Like when did you realize that,
OK, this is something that I can obsess over and try and make a
living out of it? Yeah, quite early, because I
always was interested by competition in every sports.
And when I discovered paralleling competition cross
country, I, yeah, it fascinated me.
And yeah, from there I flew quite a lot near my hometown.
And then in France, we have a high school in the Pyrenees
where it's supported by the government and we teach, we
train young people to get to get better in cross country playing.
So they have this schedule for school, the schedule for sport,
and you try to make the best out of it.
I went there when I was 15, yeah, 15 to 18.
I spent two years there and yeah, it's really probably one
of the best place you can be to really learn everything you
need. So.
Yeah. Quite early.
One question that comes from my mind is that these sports
specific schools usually have have a place in everybody's
daily routine and it's mostly about sports.
Does anybody really even study there or is it?
It's weird. It's also really serious about
shooting. Actually even a lot of of the
people who went through the whole process, they are now
engineer or it's they really don't mess with with the school
part. Sometimes I feel that we as a
community or like just as humanity try to force normal
education on people, although it's a way of discipline because
obviously passing classes and going through the curriculum
requires you to have a certain sort of mindset which should
have discipline which will help you in the sports as well.
But looking from your perspective now, since you have
seen that life and now you have lived paragliding all your years
after that, do you think studies really matter if you want to
become a good sportsman? It matters because pipelining,
it's very difficult to live from.
So yeah, I think in other sports you can maybe gamble more.
So I would say that it's still in sport.
So it's very difficult from yeah, yeah.
To just think about living from it, even if it's possible.
But it's very difficult if you are not an instructor or really
living from competition is. No, I agree.
What I meant is that does reading or putting your thought
help you become a better flier in?
I think it's it's part of the process for sure.
Because when you looked a lot of pilots here on the World Cup
tour, at some point you you need to really like think a lot.
I think like when you see guys like Luca Hammond and Batiste or
they are, they are thinking a lot.
I think you can do it more intuitively or if you, but at
some point you need to understand a lot of stuff
because it's also a matter of yeah.
Into intellectual stuff sometimes, yeah, indeed your
journey over there has been quite diverse.
In paragliding I believe you are going out and chasing the glory
and I can fly and making it count there.
And of course, the conventional racing with triple savings and
pod style harnesses. When did the diversification
start in your life? Like how did you eventually
think that, OK, these are the disciplines that I'll go in and
not acro or spot landing or anything like that?
Yeah, I can fly it. It came a bit after.
Of course I was watching the XLS, its nature and and but it
came really after because I spend a lot of energy on the
World Cup tour. And I think the point is turning
point when I wasn't selected for one world championship in 2017.
And from this moment I said maybe I give a try to the excel.
So from 2017 to 19 I start to to train quite seriously for the
race. And then, yeah, I kept the
process. I also succeeded to be a bit
more, Yeah, to find some, yeah, a way to to manage my time.
Because if you want to do both, it's really a lot of energy,
time, money also. So yeah, I would say the term is
2017, yeah. Max, I want to talk a little bit
about the hard work in our sport because conventional sports, you
see a lot of sportsmen going out there and putting in three hour
practice sessions in the morning and something similar in the
evening. And they do this either in the
middle of their teens or sometime late teens.
And then they blossom into a mature player in their early 20s
and maybe peak out late 20s and early 30s.
When we talk about legendary statuses in paralleling, the
sport comes in our lives in very different phases because
aviation is expensive and the amount of monetary freedom is
dependent upon your status and where you come from and what
your circumstances are. So the hard work that we have in
these sports is very different for everyone.
You had a pretty good start, I would say.
Let's say early teams, you were already exposed to the wings and
everything. So how did your hard work look
like? Like where did you put in the
effort that actually counts even now?
Yeah, I was lucky to start early as you said.
But yeah, it's I think what something we we recognize from
people who start quite early is it's that most of them, they do
a lot of ground handling. So when you pick some, the young
guys we are here on the tour there is like common stuff is
that they played a lot with their wings.
And I would say that, yeah, if you start with this, it's a good
point. But after when you are more
mature and and you have also a bit less time in the
professional life and everything to give an idea to prepare a
season with the Exalt and some World Cup or Worlds or European
Championship. My I divided I train like
between 900 to 950 hours season. So it's quite big amount and it
was around the 450 hours flying and four 450 entrance training.
So yeah, it's a big amount of time.
So you have to always like my weeks were planned, so I had to
do this kind of training to adapt to the weather.
But yeah, it's a lot of planning.
Let's talk a little bit about ground handling because I think
that is one thing in our sport that not a lot of pilots are
willing to do, even though they know the importance of it.
Is kiting the easiest way or should you try and do some
variations in it? Because a lot of people say
that, hey, I pulled the glider up and is standing on the top of
my head, that's good enough, That's all I need to take off.
So your youngsters who are putting in hours and hours, what
does ground handling look like for them or how did it look?
Like for you, I think for them it's fun sessions actually,
right? Yeah, playing in the wind.
And also there is something really important in in ground
landing and you find it in the air again, it's brake pressure
and stuff like this. And just developing the
sensation is something which matters a lot because you find
it in the air. So it's better to understand
when to use the brake when you don't need because of the
pressure and stuff like this. And really it's old school.
Like, yeah, old school to say this.
I have the sensation that you must do groundling, but it's the
truth and it increased your security on the take off and
everywhere. So basically it's really a
strong pattern that we see when especially I was coaching in the
Pyrenees. So I went through when I was a
teenager and now I was coaching during one year there and most
of the most of them, they have hours and hours of ramen and
really it's a lot. OK, so let's make it simple for
our listeners. You have 200 hours in a year
that you can spend on parallel lighting.
You could do 200 hours of flying or you could do 200 hours of
ground handling. How would you recommend let's
say 100 hour pilot or 100 to 500 hour pilot?
Somewhere in that range which is flying a seething, could be a
three liner, could be a 2 liner. If they have to distribute their
time wisely, how many out of 200 hours should they focus on
ground and the remaining on the air?
When you want, I think it's a bit general because it it always
depends what you want to do with your part later.
It's what's your goal and from the goal you always when you
want to achieve something, you will start from the goal and
then you do the plan. And so it's difficult to answer
this because yeah, it's it depends a lot on also the place
you are living and stuff like this.
But it's the more you are in the air, the better the conditioner
are added to your level for sure, because it's also one
really important stuff. And ground handling is, is easy
to do. You learn, you do 1015 minutes
fighting with the wing or it's yeah, it's I have some difficult
to say. Yeah, you should do 50 hours
grounding, 150 flying. Yeah, yeah, it's.
OK, not to put you in a spot, but let's say should you?
Because airtime is airtime, right?
Nothing can replace airtime. You will feel the brake pressure
in the air. And this is a dilemma which I
feel a lot of times that it looks flyable that day, but at
the same time I'm like, I still need to work on my takeoff
skills or my kiting skills. How much importance can you give
really ground handling? Because ground handling will
make you much more confident and airtime will obviously do the
same. Prioritizing airtime versus
ground handling was my question. And that's the reason I asked.
That's since if you are not really 100% confident on a take
off, I think you you should prioritize on the ground.
And because I live in Nancy and we see a lot of people on take
off who are really you see them they are afraid they don't now
know to handle. Yeah, I would say normal wind
like nothing and they are in danger.
And so it is something that shocked me in the sport because
it's too much gambling and one day, one day you will be hurt if
you continue like this. So it's always the same as soon
as yeah, if you are not comfortable on something on the
take off, yeah, you should still like progress in this.
Before I move on to the next topic, just to close up the
ground handling part, is there a certain time in life and you're
like, all right now I have done enough.
Now I can just focus on airtime rather than because ground
hunting is tough. You get sweaty, you get there's
dusty and all of those like your wing gets dragged around.
Do you reach a stage in life or in career where you're like,
yeah, I don't need any more ground hunting.
I'm good kind of a thing. No, I think it should always
keep, keep a bit of it like during winter it's good time.
Also you go playing with your wing in the apps.
We have a lot of spot that you can.
If you have some some win, you can go playing with the wing at
the top of the mountain. It's fun.
It's good training with your wing to train your abilities on
the ground and there is a lot of moment and places where you can
do it. It's yeah, you can add up during
the winter it's a bit windy and this so it's always a matter.
Yeah, we always deal with the you can basically.
Never do too much of ground handling.
It's always A+ big plus in the sport Max.
Whenever we start trying to get better in the sport, let's say
we have two 300 hours under our belt, we start getting more
intuitive. Is there a way to understand
your strengths, which things you like?
How do you find what kind of flyer you are, or what really
works for you? Or how did you navigate that?
Yeah, at some point you need to, if you want to really appreciate
what you do good and what you do wrong.
You have to confront to all the pilots because if you are a
runner, you can have the watch to you know how, yeah, you know
the time you will do for a 5 gig.
But in piloting if you are not as a pilot with you, you never
know if you have optimized the condition in a certain place.
So I would say that at some point the comparison with all
the pilots will really make you grow a lot because it's the only
way. We have to be more objective in
our way to just to fly because it's the only way to to compare
our performance is to see if someone is better in climbing.
For example, if you are always flying alone in a remote place,
I don't know, you can be the king of your valley, but you
will never know if somebody's climbing better than you.
So it's really good at some point to really fly with the
with the group to see, yeah, I can say that I'm climbing quite
well. But in the lines, when we are in
a glide, I'm always losing and I don't know why.
So at this point, you can start like asking the good questions,
but if you don't go through this process, yeah, you can fly
probably properly, but you will never know what you can.
Yeah, get better. Indeed, I think this World Cup,
even though I was not racing officially, was such a big
reality check. I remember the first time I
arrived in World Cup. It was shocking, like every
glide. I was good at climbing, but
every glide it was nightmare, yeah.
Yeah, I, I kid you not, I had a pretty good season.
I started in Kenya in Carrier Valley, and it was beautiful,
guys. I think 150 kilometers without
turning on a 200 kilometer flight.
I had to determine only three, three times in that 200
kilometer flight. And I was like, geez, you're
getting good. And then I come here and I have
three bum bolts in a row. Let's say it's for sure it's
you. You need this comparison at some
point. Max, I want to talk a little bit
about ours because when we start the sport, depending upon
whenever you start in your life and how much freedom you have,
some people are thinking 100 is good enough.
Some people think 500 is good enough.
And then you reach a level of 1002 thousand.
And then there are people like you who are having, I don't
know, beyond 5000 or something. You stop counting after a while
and even then there is room for improvement.
Have you seen that? What is the amount of hours that
a person starts understanding what the game is all about?
Yeah. It's always, always think about
according the goals. But what we see people wanting
to get, yeah, to a good level to a World Cup tour, for example.
The thing we recognize when they start a bit from scratch is that
they fly really a lot like, like we have some example like
Francois Manchuri or, or yeah, I could say a lot of them.
At some point there was Benoiters who did the Excel also
and but they fly like between 400 to 500 hours because they
are really motivated. They want to achieve this.
It's the extreme cases because Benoit, for example, he reached
the excerpts after three years of playing, but in three years
maybe he flew like 1500 hours, something like that every year,
not in total. So 500, so it's big amount.
So if the goal is really I want to perform like this, of course
you need hours and then yeah. Then when you are more
experienced, it's a bit different because you learn
already a lot. If you fly a bit less, that's
not what will make you worst. It's at some point, of course,
if you the you have the world championship in 15 days and you
didn't yeah fly for three months, you are maybe in
trouble. But if you decrease the amount
of flying on your long it's and your experience, it's not yeah,
big matter of trouble. But yeah, you need to fly if the
goal is in the I have the interview of Regal, I think just
before the Exalt, he said my goal is to fly 200 hours, your
experience so I can be fit for the Exalt in the air.
So yeah, it always depends how you're planning your goals.
But it's 5400. Five, 500 hours is really a lot
in the sport. It's really a lot because the
weather time you are. Are you talking about turmeric
or combined? Not combined.
So soaring turmeric, whatever, because they're only tunneling
it. Yeah, yeah.
I don't know. I mean Yahweh is the test pilots
like Wuhan is flying, but maybe more than this.
Yeah, yeah, Around that, they're the ones who are flying the most
in the sport. I think so.
Yeah, pretty much they are. In the air, every day, every
flyable days. All the life difficult.
OK, Max, I want to talk a little bit about goal setting that
comes priorities change, feelings change.
Sometimes you like flying more, sometimes you like flying less.
Just like any other thing in life when it comes to goal
setting, is there is there a way you feel it from your inside or
you ask some questions for you or is just intuition that this
is where I feel like, or how can you realistically set your
expectations versus the effort that you're putting in?
Yeah, I like to. It's just so you take the goal
and you take the qualities it is which is required to achieve it.
Of course if you're flying since 2 years and you want to achieve
the first 400 kilometers, if I triangle maybe it's too early
and but I think it's you take the goal and it's pretty good
just and make the plan from it. So I don't know if you want, if
you are a pilot who wants to fly the 1st 100K, 400K at 15 at 15
kilometers average. It's yeah, it's six hours.
The thing is to already you can start first from this.
I need to fly, I need to be able to fly six hours.
So yeah, what it means, it means that you have to have a good
volume because flying six hours is tiring because even for pilot
like me in the World Cup or at the beginning of the season,
flying 234 hours is demanding and in the middle of the scene
and it's power play. So yeah, you start from there.
So I, I need to have good volume so I can.
Yeah, and dual and I need to fly 15 kilometers per hour during
six hours. What is required.
So it requires climbing in terminal because then flying on
bar and stuff like this is much. Yeah, it's not the first thing.
It's really I'm able to stay unable to Yeah, be able to
terminal any terminal like a little one big one.
So this is the base for me. Yeah, 100 Ki need all this
what's at the moment my qualities OK, I'm able to fly
maybe 3 hours it's not enough. So I need to step up to to
really make my volume grow and yeah and be able to stay in the
air. So staying in the air is
terminally. So endurance building is one of
the key aspects, as you mentioned, because we don't feel
it, but the rain really consume a lot of energy.
And yeah, it's what I said at the beginning of the season, 2
hours is a lot and in July is nothing because you need to
train the brain and the things aside like hydration, all this.
But yeah, always start from the goal, what it needs and.
I was going to save this topic for later but we're talking
about it. So how do you feel yourself from
the flights? Can you talk a little bit about
your pre flight meal and mid flight and post flight?
What does your nutrition look like?
Yeah, I was really bad at it. I had to get better in a way.
Thank you for your honesty. Because it's when you do the
Excel, it becomes really an important topic because if you
are really always focused in years, sometimes you forget get
to drink. Basically what I try to to do
before is to try to eat enough carbs.
It's the main things for me because it's what it's what the
brain consume a lot and in the air.
Actually it's I try sometimes to eat something, but the best for
me it's the dehydration power. How do we say the carbs you can
do, you can put in the water. Yeah.
So just like get. Hydration powder or stuff like
this and I try to have between yeah, 30 to 50 grams of carbs an
hour so for yeah so yeah, it's what I try to do suits the
optimistic plan. Sometimes you forget to drink
or, but that's the idea. And and I have also some gels or
stuff like this if I have time to.
But my main thing on a World Cup task or stuff like this is it's
to have carbs in the water because it's easy.
You drink and you have to train it because it's for people who
are really focused in the air. It's even difficult to just do
this. And for me, it was difficult.
And now I try to, every time I exit the terminal, I try to
drink just one sip or two sip. It's just my thing.
Just you exit the terminals, you drink.
Wow. Yeah.
That's such a good way of making sure that you stay hydrated.
Yeah. Because if you don't, if you
don't set something like this, you yeah, you don't drink.
And I was really bad at it. Like really bad.
How do you how comfortable is pissing for you in the I could
have used a better. Word.
That's the reality. No, no, I have no trouble with
this like with the pain index that like this.
I know some people they are unable to yeah to pee in year.
I think practice just try taking a piss in the simulator when
you're hanging the harness. Maybe that is the.
Way to get some people so like they were really unable to pee
in year and just start to put this stuff at the office and
sitting inside. Yeah, because.
Or in the car. Or if it's because you have to
train this for the people who don't succeed.
But yeah. Do you, do you have a kind of
time in the air when you take a leak?
Because let's say gliding is one of the least stressful time
Terminally, you're tensing of your core muscles, right?
So it's hard to release. There is people under you.
That's one way to try and win the task, Yeah, just put others
concentration on the ground. They are not really happy about
it. You can't get disqualified for
it. Yeah, you can have it pronounced
here. Oh, OK, no, but.
During the glides, most most likely during the like the
glides and trying to see if there is nobody the blind, but
you can just. Go away and yeah, shit.
Interesting, interesting. Jeez, well talks like this make
me lose my thought process. I forgot what I was.
Yes, post flight nutrition I think.
I don't know how your general alcohol consumption habits are,
but over the past few days that I've seen you here, you have
either ordered a non alcoholic beer or I haven't seen a glass
of beer in your hand. Not yesterday evening, no.
Actually it's the for me, this competition is I'm here without
any goals. Actually it's one of the first
time because after the exam and everything, I didn't wanted to
go. So I I think I drink some beers
during this week, but I never do normally.
Yeah, never. It's really the first time.
So now alcohol is really bad. Actually, after the flight it's
the worst idea you can have because dehydrates you even
more. So there is really no point to
drink a beer, even beer, because there is still this myth about
beer that it hydrates you. That's totally false.
But one of the move sometimes that you see also in cycling,
the first thing they do after crossing the finish line, they
drink something really sugary. That's a good moment to do it
because the body really requires some sugar after flight like we
do in the World Cup or in the Excel.
You really like your, your calves amount has really
decreased. So you really need something
like this. I saw this because I volunteered
in Commonwealth Games in 2010 and I was volunteering in the
cycling section and I recall, I think it was Irish team or
something handing out cans of Coke to their riders almost two
or three laps before reaching the finish.
So what I was thinking is that does it make sense that we also
sip in Coke before going on the final or before the final turn
point or something like that? The powder hydration we were
talking about this is this effect with it's not the same
sort of sugar. It's it's a bit healthier, yeah,
but yeah, that's the idea to keep a good level of carbs
going. But yeah, after the finish line,
it's really a moment where your muscle are and brain are can the
muscle can stock the sugar and so it's.
The depleted levels that you've lost during the flight.
OK, yeah. So all the pilots that you see
going in for beers at the goal are like easier, not really
worst idea. Why do we even have that?
It's now for me, it's one thing that's it's a bit hard to do
this, but it's a shame to have this in the goal.
One side we yeah, yeah. For me it's not professional to
propose beer to pilot in official race.
I know sometimes I'm a bit maybe.
Yes we would. Yeah, not fun enough.
But yeah, I don't see the point. No, that's exactly what I was
going to say, that one side we are trying to make the sport
more professional and on the other end we are offering
alcohol right away, especially when you're thirsty, when the
temptations are at their highest and you're like, hey, get drunk
and. No, I really don't understand
why we. Interesting this.
I think every person can make their own decisions.
So but the yeah, the image, she's not really good if she won
the that is it to say that they want to upgrade the sport more
professional and stuff like this.
But you start sometime with things.
Like you can never imagine footballers or anybody getting
box of chilled beer in the locker room after a game.
Making the rugby, they did this for about 20 or 30 years.
Interesting, interesting. Max, before I move on, I want to
talk about FOMO because FOMO is something very fear of missing
out, very common in our sport. And be it wing progression, be
it gliding at the highest level, FOMO is one thing which effects
pretty much everyone in the sport, from beginners to
professionals. Have you decoded a way to not
let? Emotions like this affect you
and your decision making and goal setting in short term as
well as in long term. I see a lot of people around me
actually at the moment having this.
They always feel that if they don't like go flying when they
have some time and the conditions sometimes are a bit
like on the edge, they still go because yeah, maybe I'm missing
something. But what I say to to them is
especially that they are not like high level competitors or
it's, it's better to have a higher volume in standard
conditions than pushing in marginal or really change
conditions because it's where you can get fear and be.
Shocked. The finger injury, yeah.
Yeah, I have really lot, lot of example of people getting
shocked by something, even if it's not the worst thing in the
world. Like it's just sometimes a big
collapse quite far from the mountain, but it stays somewhere
and it's the beginning sometimes of really seeing them declining.
The level is decreasing because they are shocked and and really
it's going without being pretty sure that the condition fits
your level. It's one of the main points in
populating, yeah, I think. OK, this brings me to a question
that is a huge that level that has remained in my life for
quite a while, ever since it started, and I'm so glad that it
came to mind. Right now, that is.
To get better, you have to push your limits.
But there is a sweet spot where you stop pushing because yeah,
yeah, you have to push a bit. But it's not when we train the
young pilot for the French Federation, what we recognize,
OK, we have to make them flying in a bunch of conditions, but
the I would trade 100 times higher volume.
It's in standard conditions, OK, It's not too windy, it's not
like high risk of thunderstorm and everything against flying in
really marginal condition, because there is still common.
How do we say the common mindset?
Yeah, the cultural stuff in our spot to think that if you really
fly in really strange condition, then you know better.
But that's not true. If you prepare the exile, maybe
you have to push yourself in this condition sometimes, not
always, sometimes. But if you prepare World Cup or
stuff like this, you don't. Yeah.
What one of the rule we had when we trained the younger guys is
if we would cancel the task, we don't fly because yeah, there is
no point in not being specific in the training.
So you are not specific and you take risks.
So at some point there is no point.
Wow, that's such a good analogy. Taking risk for nothing,
basically. Yeah, if you see this week as
soon as there was really high winds, the task was just cancel.
So what's the point to go flying in 40K per hour when in your
training you will not do it? So if you want to be specific,
be specific. Yeah, yeah, that that makes
total sense. And I want to anything you want
to add. No after no just for I can fly
races. It's a bit different because you
you know there is a bunch of other conditions.
It's also depending on the level of risk you want to take.
Which is a whole different topic basically.
Risk management management really big topic.
But you know, that is where I wanted to come actually is that
fatigue management and I'll be very thankful if you can be open
about it. But if not, it's like whatever
is your comfort zone, aviation and fatigue don't go well,
that's a given. Like pilots and commercial
airlines have a mandate mandatory rest period for a
reason and that is that your cognitive ability need a reset
time. But we as a sport have developed
some branches where fatigue is starting to look down upon and
we are glorifying the constant pushing of human body endurance
and the abilities. What is your take on a pilot
battling fatigue yet trying to go out and achieve the
objectives? He's more at risk.
He's, he's for sure because, yeah, there is different kind of
fatigue because we if we take, if you take the Excel, for
example, the fatigue come quite early in the race.
And it's really the extreme stuff.
And I remember not being clear in the air because of this,
because you only sleep like 4 hours a night and this so you
can handle it one day, 2 days, three days.
And after this you start to see that everything is is getting a
bit weird. So I remember 1 flight in 23, I
think 21, I don't know, But basically I was falling asleep
in the air in I was at 4000 meters in really, really
difficult condition. And still I was starting to fall
asleep. Yeah.
I was just giving me like, I don't know, in English, but
slapping, yeah, slapping myself, yeah, I had to stay awake.
So this is the extreme part because I think, yeah, it's hard
to something, but the real life is nothing, nothing.
But in a day of normal pilot there is there is a lot of stuff
can be a stressful life. So if you're working a lot and
you say, ah, maybe I can go flying at the end of the day,
yeah, it's good to ask yourself the question how am I feeling?
And sometimes is we come back to the formal stuff.
Most of them they are pushing. Yeah, I will go and sometimes it
work out because it can be a nice evening flight, but you
always have to adapt. OK, if it's going to nice
evening flight, normal conditions, no problem.
It's OK. You end up the condition take
off good, no problem. I think it's it can even yeah
makes life better also, but it is to yeah, go pushing in the
mirror for the afternoon in strong term.
I think what's the point if you feel like really bad?
Let me try. And yeah, because I'm coming
from conventional sports, because human psychology is
based on relating our experiences with other things
that the other members of the tribe does, or whatever the
society do to become a better marathon runner.
There's a reason why Kenyans are so good at it because they train
in higher temperatures and they are less easily dehydrated than
Europeans. So they willingly go out and
test their bodies endurance in positions which are difficult.
But at the same time, I had Julian, your coach on the show a
few days ago and he said that this sport is something that you
should only practice if you're willing to die for it, which was
a big statement. But it is so true that anything
can happen to anyone at any point in time because air is
invisible and we humans are not born to fly.
So when it comes to building endurance, and I can relate to
this to my own personal experience, I live in Norway and
the FOMO is huge there because we only get 3 months out of 12
which are realistically cross country weather.
So unless you're acro or spot landing by that you will miss
out. And then you see X contest
blowing up in Alps and this cross country sending you these
amazing stories. So whenever I get a chance to
fly, I want to maximize my airtime at the cost of fatigue.
And I remember there was a flight when I was falling asleep
4 hours into it and it was just soaring flight.
There was nothing that was demanding.
And I was like, I'm pretty high 1002 thousand meters above the
ground, nothing's going to happen.
So let me just try and nap a little.
Which was stupid I'm not going to lie.
But the point was that I knew that I had to reach at least 60
hours that year to be current on my C wing, endurance, building
hardware and fatigue. It's like, how do you reach a
point where you stop lying to yourself that hey, this is
becoming dangerous, and if I don't stop, this could very well
be the last time I'm given a chance by life to do this.
Yeah, it's. I think it's also culture
sometimes, the notion of fear. It's from not one pilot to
another. It's really striking the
difference you can see. And as Julian said, it's also
about philosophy. Yeah.
Am I willing to die for it? But yeah, What what I recognize
as an instructor or when you talk to people, most of the time
they feel it. They feel something inside.
Today is something off with me. So I think sometimes you have to
trust the feeling. Intuition.
Yeah, the intuition. And The thing is, yeah.
To always. Yeah, to always.
Yeah. If I don't fly today, OK, that's
OK, actually, that's OK. That's there will be another
flyable day. There will be.
So for me, it's really the feeling.
Like I have the feeling when something is wrong, I have the
feeling that I can know it because my body is yeah, giving
alerts or so mostly I think intuition feeling, gut feeling,
there is many name for it, but I have the the feeling that that
most of the time when something is wrong with our state, the
body sends them. Have you ever tried to fight
your gut? Yeah, most of the time in the
race, like the XLP, you've you go against.
I talk for myself because maybe all the guys, they don't feel
this fear, but I fight a lot of shouldn't.
Sorry to stop you in between but I'm very tempted to point in my
experience there's a take off in Oslo which is about the city.
Super sketchy. Like literally half a second to
abort. If not, you either have to
commit or you have to be ready to be rescued from the trees by
the fire department. I fight my gut a lot there that
like that is the only way to make it count.
Otherwise I will pack my wing and go back home 8 out of 10
times in a month or whenever. So how much should you really
listen to your gut? Or am I not putting in the
effort so that I don't have to I my gut doesn't have to call me
again and say that hey. Yeah, maybe this take off is too
dangerous. Yeah, No, but really what I
think is sometimes we accept things that are like here, we do
it and we don't ask the good questions.
And if you feel that it's recognised by a lot of pilot
that it's really a sketchy place.
I think there is problem with the place, not with your
feelings or that's the thing that for me.
So it's we, I think we with Excel stuff and we develop also
the idea through the community that in a way it's always it's
always possible to take off from here.
We did. We saw so much crazy take off
landings and stuff like this, but actually not every place is
really good to take off. Not every place is good to land.
It's so maybe the place you're talking about it's just not fit
for. It's just not Yeah else for
flying. Can't I train myself out of that
bad gut feeling by? Technique.
Maybe it's analysing the take off.
What makes it so difficult? Is it a Cliff?
Is it something you can understand and recognise
patterns and the conditions? I think there is analysing the
place maybe better to understand better the problems and then you
can have a better idea when to go there, when not to go there.
Or can I train another way to take off like, I don't know,
Cobra or I don't know, maybe there is a ways to sort it out.
But that's why we come back to to ground anything and stuff
like this. But because if you know a lot of
techniques, then you can add up. So you can add up with maybe
some technical stuff. But then if the place is really
yeah, not understandable, or it's too difficult, there is no
patterns, maybe it's not a good place to play.
No I agree. I agree that's just accept the
truth and stop running away from the reality basically.
Yeah, yeah there was. Yeah.
There is many time with with some take off in places and I
can play races and it's not just about techniques.
It's like bit of gambling. How do you make peace with the
fact that you challenge your gut when you should not have and
still got away with it or you were given another chance that
OK, how do you look back when you have those kind of
instances? Yeah, I have good examples.
At some points you recognise sometimes when you are not
totally objective concerning conditions.
So it's when the pattern come back.
Today it's a bit windy, but I know that in some way my feeling
says it's not really good, but I've done it a lot.
I repeatedly did it like I have an idea of crossing in my own
mountains near and see I have a where I know that it's possible.
So after doing it a lot, still the feeling is not really good
that it will be turbulent or stuff like this, but you can
handle because I have the skids and stuff like this.
I have to repeat it and it's not an extreme situation.
It's not 50K win. It's just difficult places to
handle. But I've done it many times.
So I tried to find confidence in this, to try to fight it.
And sometimes when I'm not really not happy to fight it,
that I have fought it, yeah, I just try to analyse and say why
did I take this decision? Because maybe I was in
competition, I wanted to push more.
But since the Excel 23 also, I have really understand my
limits. And now I'm fighting more demons
because of it. Because now I'm afraid in
situation that I was not afraid before.
And it's it's a really long process now.
So when you touch your limits or you go really outside your
limits, it's where the troubles began most of the time.
Because yeah, you shock your brain.
True, thank you for saying it so honestly.
You know, it's very hard to be open about such things, but if
more people can realise that there is a limit.
Yeah, there is limit because I had some cool talks with people
thinking that when you do the Excel, then after you can find
any condition. That's really false, like it's
untrue. We can't.
Our park riders have limits, the pilots have limits.
So at some point there is no point to fly in some condition
with with this talking part like this.
Yeah, we all are humans after all.
Let's talk a little bit about glorification of our sport by
social media. It's a part of life that we
cannot escape from. Algorithms of Instagram and
Facebook will influence every single human out there who has
Internet, which is pretty much the norm.
Young pilots will be exposed to these videos or even experienced
ones. I don't know if they put data
scientists behind it or how they make us feel the formal and make
us want to do it. But if you are a pilot who is
watching only supposedly the good side, because bad sides are
not exaggerated as much, especially by the organisations
who run these things. They love to show one side of
the perspective. How can you as a consumer try
and protect yourself when you do not know the unknown that is
being hidden from you? I think also it's the
responsibility of the athletes sometimes to show the the
reality of this kind of races or to warn people.
Sometimes I because what we've done, what we do during the
exhab sometimes is in my opinion, it's my opinion, but
it's totally crazy. I have seen really crazy things
in this race and it's so crazy sometimes that now I'm not even
there is the shock of 23. But yeah, now the motivation is
really difficult to keep for me because I said that I think I
have done, I will not take as much risk as some of them.
And it's difficult to me to say, OK, maybe just there is no point
because I will never do this. Flying under the lightning is an
example of the crazy thing. We'll see.
So I think it's part of the responsibility of the athletes.
Sometimes the problem is that when something quite crazy and
the race occurs, everybody talks about it.
It was fucking scary and stuff like this.
And when it's finished and nobody talks about it and that
the media, you will never find something really like the
reality of it. Yeah, I think we have a
responsibility on it. The problem is now what works on
the social media is short videos.
And we all know what works. And I think it's more going
through like maybe podcasts like you do, but also writing.
And it takes time to just. We know that it's not working to
warn people because the algorithm is killing it.
So I don't know. You're becoming a Dumber
generation by the time. Yeah, yeah, we don't read the
brain rotors. Read what is I learned when I
was young, I learned a lot thanks to guys like Luke Armour
or there is a lot of guys like him.
But because they wrote a lot about the sport and you can read
about the cross country flying or stuff like this.
But it's more much more inspiring to read because when
you read you are in the mind of someone else.
So when you read Luke, for example, you are like you have a
window on how is feeling the air mass and how he's like judging
for things. So it's really more like it's 10
times better than watching a 30 seconds video. 100.
Percent. But it's not, it's not the way
we are going. Yeah, that's quite a shame.
And to be honest, like picking up a book because I, I embarked
on this trip almost a week ago, like when everybody came here on
18th, 19th and I was like, shit, there is a book that no matter
what happens, I will finish before I finish my vacation.
It's a very good leadership book if you want to inspire others.
And I was like, if I'm running a podcast, I need to inspire
others. So let me see like a week into
this and I've had three rest days and I still haven't picked
up a book because somehow my brain doesn't.
I've made in. I studied the literature after
my high school and now I'm not reading like I'm reading again a
bit, but with the fucking cell phone.
Like you're always trapped in screen time and yeah, it's now
an effort to do something else when you have a free little free
time. We should grab a book or read a
story of Luke or someone else but we just have 32nd bullshit
video. Do you meditate or do you What's
your way to unwind, basically? My sorry.
Unwinding, taking time away from this passion of or this is
defining your life I believe so how do you disconnect
paragliding? I think I didn't disconnect
enough the last years and I'm a bit of obsessed with it because
if there is a competition somewhere, I will watch the live
tracking because I know I really like to see, because
competition, you see a lot of patterns coming back and you can
actually predict pretty well what will happen when you
confront the people here, the people who are here, the
condition, the patterns, their abilities, their qualities and
their. And yeah, when you, you put all
the parameters and somehow you can, you can.
Yeah. Decode the next move.
Yeah. Interesting.
It's interesting. But yeah, I have trouble to to
do something else actually, because it's also my work.
It's so yeah, it's. And when I was doing something
else, it was training endurance, but it was for the Excel.
Yeah, it's like the ecosystem. Yeah.
Interesting. No, But what I'm wondering is,
let's say, first of all, how does it feel to have #1 return
on a glider? Man, that's kind of cool, you
know? Yeah, what the Super final was.
I achieve it when I was the first one when I was 22 years
old. Wow.
Yeah, that was 2013. I think I was 14.
Yeah, OK. And it was really a strong
feeling, but it was also difficult to process after
because you know that during 5-6 days you you reach a dream and
you think that forever you will have the sensation of it.
But it's fading fast. Yeah, yeah, it's fading super
fast. And it's always the same.
And then I was the world champion and, and yeah, it's
still the same. The only difference is 2 days
after I was at the ex house, I had no time to process it.
But after all this, there is always, you have the top
sensation and then super fast, you feel a bit empty.
You reach something you wanted quite dearly.
And then, yeah, it's what am I doing now?
Yeah, it's it's so you have the up and sometimes a bit the down
after the Super final. This time was was a bit
different because I've done it one time before.
But it's sometimes the World Cup tour in the community is is not
well understood. It's not because it's, it looks
really difficult to understand the scoring, but complicated.
Trust me, the guys flying here, the top 50s, they are really
strong with apply there. They are really strong.
Yeah. The density of pilots is
growing. Yeah.
It's when you start to achieve things.
It's that your technical, tactical level is, it's pretty
high. But still, do you look up and
feel good that there's normal one on your ankle?
Yeah, it's damn man. Good thing.
Yeah. The reason why I ask that is
because, of course, getting #1 on your wing is not an easy
task. You, you request sacrifice,
dedication, like the whole story behind it, because reaching the
pinnacle is hard enough, but maintaining that level is even
harder from what I've seen. So how do you think that?
OK, I want to become a better pilot?
What is your hard work looking like at this stage in your life?
For me or. Yeah, for you, where do you pick
up your sources, as you said, like reading, where's your trust
factor at this moment? It seems a bit weird to do this,
but my confidence level is really low actually at the
moment because since I'll talk about it, it's pretty personal,
but since 23 in the I really like struggle with park
lighting. Yeah, it seems totally like,
yeah, not rational because I was in 24 like European champion and
the Super final. But I'm really struggling with
training because of the exact and how far we went and I how
far I went in these conditions because it was the worst
condition of my life. And now I have to to face really
a lot of doubt and I feel sometimes really uncomfortable
in the air. It's like when I have elements
of the context, high wind, high mountains and being alone, it's
really difficult for me. So yeah, I have to fight this.
I work with psychologists and everything because it look a lot
like post traumatic stress. So there is also someone here
studying the subject about paralleling.
It will maybe be the first subject.
Yeah, interesting about it, but it's another topic.
But I'm fighting this just And when I have no elements of the
context, like in the European it was gaggle flying flatlands, not
really windy. I can fly to my best level, but
sometimes when I'm flying at home in really classical
condition in the arts, it's very difficult.
So yeah, that's why also I struggle a bit with motivation
and stuff like this. So it's really when you see the
results, you see it's at the top level.
But I don't have this feeling actually at.
The moment. I'm sorry to hear that, man.
Yeah, it's the process, but it's also good.
Yeah, A good reminder for people that what we do sometimes in the
this race, I have maybe some other race, but this one, yeah,
it's it can be shocking sometimes it shocks some people.
You mean the Alps or the World Cup?
Not because the World Cup. Yeah, you can solve the task.
Yeah. Yeah, something is really
dangerous. I'm I have of course some tasks.
Maybe we went to be too far, but most of the tasks we do, it's
really safe in the air. So even though PWCA puts beers
at the goal, but it still doesn't make us do look stupid
in the air. Yeah, sometimes we do stupid
things, but most of the time it's OK.
Yeah, sure, sure. Now thank you for, you know,
sharing that and I hope you catch your mojo back.
Is that the way I'm? Working on it.
You know, I actually wanted to ask you this because I myself
have this question a lot of times is that nobody talks about
the real cost of chasing passion because first of all, finding
passion doesn't come easy in your life, right?
There are a lot of aimless people out there who are finding
enough reasons to just get addicted in one indulgence or
the other. Could be smoking, could be
drinking, gambling, whatever. Could be gaming, could be
scrolling. So finding passion itself is a
blessing and then finding the courage to chase the passion is
the next step. But then going all the way with
that courage, keeping motivated, playing your cards right,
putting in the hard work takes a lot from life.
I was talking to Will Gad on the show a few episodes earlier and
he said eventually the point is to look back and say that I have
lived a good life and be happy with the fact the way you have
spent it so. We do find a lot of meaning in
pursuing passion up to the highest level, but the real cost
that is behind the scenes that nobody except you, maybe your
parents or maybe your close contacts like the ones who see
you very often only see that. Is it really worth it man?
Yeah, I think it's worth it. But because if you.
Yeah, in the I think sometimes the life is a big chaos, but
yeah, you're having a way to to find something that makes you
happy. If you so it's what Will said
probably. But if you don't do it, then
what would you do? Yeah, but sometimes it costs a
lot. I mean, because you some when
you don't succeed, you get like upset and sometimes you don't
find solution. And also sometimes when it's a
big part of your life, you can feel like yeah, yeah, sometimes
you can feel a bit like. And if I lose it, what would I
do? I would be lost if tomorrow you
say to me, OK, you don't do you can't do 5 lining anymore.
Shit. Yeah, it's.
I would love to change a lot of stuff.
Yeah, it's in one hand, it's yeah, it's sometimes difficult
to dwindle, to be a bit obsessed with something, but it's also
what makes yeah, life a bit better.
I try sometimes There is this famous quote of, I think Charlie
Chaplin when I sometimes I'm too much like pessimist or I yeah,
maybe yeah, to focus on the stuff.
And I am Yeah. I forget to to look around and I
try to always think that, you know, if she.
I think the quote is the when when you shot someone in close
up, it's a drama. But when you shot the scene like
zoom out, you zoom out. It's always a comedy.
Like it's because when you focus like too much on on your
problems, you tend to be a bit too much dramatic.
But it's only part lighting. It's just, yeah, it's so when
you zoom out, sometimes life is good.
It's you just have to remember because it's easy to just, yeah,
be angry to yourself. Yeah, well, I mean like again,
like because Michael Phelps like how did he become the greatest
years staring at the black lion in the pool sacrificing on so
many times not. Swimming either, Yeah. 50m but
you're literally a human fish in a pond like you're just stuck
there for. And informing the Pyrenees that
there is also swimming like a structure for so we saw we see
them like 6:00 in the morning or.
Yeah, doing the laughs. OK, OK, let's talk about what is
your best way to get rid of switch off.
That is what I, I think asked you earlier.
Like, how do you distract yourself before the obsession
becomes too much? Because a little bit of
obsession is needed, or maybe a lot of obsession is needed to
reach the place where you have or anybody else wishes to.
But how do you make sure that you don't enter a burnout?
Or how do you come out of a burnout whenever you do?
Because it hits us all. Yeah, it's sometimes I I need to
fly a bit less and do something else, be able to go in just in
vacation without the wing and but it come it comes back pretty
fast. But now it's always also about.
I see a lot of people also. I was doing the same when I was
a young pilot. When you raise the bar really
high, it's it brings always a lot of frustration.
And so sometimes you have to set the goal a bit lower so you can
achieve them. And yeah, going a bit more step
by step. And because sometimes I see a
lot of people like yeah, getting really upset or frustrated
because of but. Yeah, I'm so glad you mentioned
this because I'll tell you what, yesterday was tricky as hell for
the listeners. The context we are talking about
the last task of this paragliding World Cup 2025 in
Macedonia. Where would you like to talk
about the task? Because you were obviously much
further off than me. I just went really far in the
past. Yeah, actually.
But but yeah, it was S SE wind pretty stable.
Yeah. And in the flatlands, yeah, it
was mainly the beginning of the task was mainly headwind.
Yeah, you started with the most difficult part and the tricky
task. So anyways the reason why I
bought this off is because when I came to this World Cup my I'm
flying a triangle which is a 2 1/2 liner and there's no way it
can keep up with triple CS. That's a no brainer.
So my idea was to just learn, watch the lines that you guys
take, try and circle. And of course I have failed
unfortunately in all of my objectives.
Yesterday when you guys were glading out and I saw a lot of
triple C's, super low, you know, some were landing, some were
almost at the time of landing. And I was like, don't even try.
Like this is not going to go well for you.
And I came back and toplanded. I somehow made it back and
toplanded. I was a bit frustrated.
I was sad. I was like, dude, you like,
because the other tasks I made, at least one day I made the
first turn point. The other day I made a second
turn point. And this one, I didn't even try
the first turn point. So I was like, I'm failing in my
objectives of this fight. And then I bumped into you at
the packing area at the hotel and you had the calm of Roger
Federer. To say the least.
That is what I saw on your face. How do you manage to not be mad?
Or how do you process emotions when things have not got us free
of land? Yeah, you know, I throw a lot of
helmet in my life. So no, I wasn't always like
this. It's also we talked about it,
but I have in on this competition really.
I had no goal just to try to yeah, enjoy a bit.
So that's not high frustration to be landed maybe too early.
And I know the competition I would have probably more upset
for, but on this one, yeah, it's OK.
Like it was part of the deal. So yeah, I am really no, yeah,
big stuff coming. But I think one of the to be
maybe a bit more constructive when you it's important to know
how to even in the air to adjust the goals.
Yeah, the condition, I'm not the one expected.
What can I do different from I had the big plan, but now maybe
the big plan was a bit too optimistic.
What can I do? What can I do different?
What can I do? I can maybe focus on a technical
stuff. You know, with the young people
we coach, we focus a lot on terminaling.
So there is a nice a nice game we do with this with them.
It's the king of the term. OK.
So yeah, you have to always. It's yeah, the one who with at
the top of the term was really a cloud based win basically.
And the idea when it comes to terminaling, we work a lot on
one Rd. is if someone's under you, really if out climb you,
it's a shame. So it's the little game we do
like it's refocusing. OK, we can't maybe do the big
cross country flight we wanted, but we can still fly terminals
and we can play this game with people.
So yeah, it's refocusing on something else sometimes.
But yeah, then the yeah, managing the frustration, then
it's yeah, it's I had a lot of trouble with this when I was
young, so maybe I learn step by step.
But I remember competition I landed and during two or three
days I was upset, like really unable to change my mind.
And, and these moments you need to, I think, yeah, it's really
personal stuff. I think it's, it depends on
people. Some of them are forgetting
really fast and be able to be like 100% for the next one.
And other pilots, they need to do something.
Yeah. So yeah, it's, it really depends
for me, yeah, it, it took years to, yeah, to be at peace when
I've done something a bit wrong. Is there a suggestion or advice
you would give to somebody else younger on who's struggling or
who wants to be a bit more peaceful with not ATV?
Yeah, what I mean there is there is a really.
Sometimes refocusing on the fun part is is important, but I
think it's it's where and we always start.
We try to start a bit early. Also with the people we coach is
the mental preparation with someone who knows the keys and
will understand what you need because it's really personal.
It can be a like maybe throwing your helmet is part of the
process and then you're OK, better the the helmet is not too
expensive, but maybe it's part of the process.
You throw something and then you feel a bit better.
Maybe it's but now no, but we are joking.
But everybody different on this level because yeah, Oh no, for
example, just manage this really good like frustration elans and
then a few minutes later he can smile and OK, I will I will be
able to win the day after. Even yesterday is another
example because the overall ranking was quite far, but he
didn't leave the fun about yeah, I have an opportunity today and
you catch it and yeah. I was surprised because a lot of
other pilots who had not done the work that he has done over
the years would be just frustrated and giving up.
I think he was an 8 years or like some crazy position.
Yeah, it was quite hard. Yeah.
And he got on the podium simply because of that skill and
perseverance. And yeah.
Doesn't lose the fun. And if there is the opportunity,
yeah, he's always here. Yeah, I can count them.
Damn, I want to get to skill development but since you
mentioned horror And how is your relation with horror?
Great. Actually really cool.
We know each other for a really long time now because yeah, I
think since we are 14 or 15 years old.
Oh wow. OK.
You ready? Yeah, 15, I think.
And yeah, it's always since the last big competition, we are
always in confrontation. There is some part of the
competition where we are super focused of us.
There is, I think no tension or it's the game.
It's for me, it's it start to be funny actually.
And we know now it's each other really.
The strong points, low points. Yeah, each other, yeah.
And I remember when the last task of the European, this guy,
he was giving everything. I saw it in the term of like
super precise. And I was thinking, I will never
be at rest with this guy. I have to go all the way just.
And I it was a task you're talking about.
Task 8 was the last one. Yeah.
No, the task, the glide. You mean on the wells?
Maybe the one which only you and him.
So this was the world championship on this one.
He made this special thing, special move.
Say, I will try to make them land all on the speed section
because we went on the glide really early.
I know the place really well. We know that at some point we
will face the valley wind and and I saw him leaving the
terminal super early and I think I thought, fuck, it's the
moment. It's really the moment where you
can win or lose the world. And so he attacks everybody
super low and in this valley, normally you don't find any
fucking term. It's a really green Alpine
valley with a lot of valley breeze and managed to find one
and just I just arrived grabbing the stuff with him, but it
wasn't climbing. It was a 0, but it was helping
us to get closer from the goal. It's one of the most tense
moments of my life, career I would say, because I know that
if I lose the zero, I lose the title.
But it was the special move, the special 1 he likes.
He really likes the situation where he's low and everybody's
with him. Yeah, you really, you don't know
how, but if only one one of us can make him make it, it's him,
that's for sure. What's the secret?
The secret is I think he's more relaxed in this situation than
someone else. I think also that it comes from
the flatlands, a bit like me also, but at the beginning and
you work a lot on low saves and there is a lot of learning in
this really. A lot is really relaxing these
situations and determining why why is is yeah super strong
also. So he's just put in the work.
Basically, yeah. For me, it's a skill that you
develop because he's coming from this part of the of France where
you fly in a flat. So yeah, Low saves a lot and
it's all together. It makes him super strong in
this, in this moment. I think your kind of friendship
rivalry in the air is like Nadal versus Federer kind of a thing.
A horror sport? No.
Yeah, I like, I like. When he came back yesterday from
the flight flight, I told him you were lucky as well, as
always. The first thing I told him
because it's a joke, like because he's always in the good
plan when something is a bit like when the task is a bit like
weird or is always in a good plan.
So it's the joke. We do.
Yeah. But my instructor said that
paragliding people who win in paragliding are usually really
lucky. But why is it the same pilots
who get a key all the time? Yeah, yeah.
When you the pro now you can rely really on the world
ranking. You can predict quite easily out
what the the ranking would be like on the competition because
there is like really big profile, like on our own, but
also Sebas, Ospina, super strong in the moment, Batiste and when
there is this guy, if they are not in the podium, yeah, it's a
problem. Messed up, but yeah.
Yeah. Do you ever check your rankings
like from time to time or it was like, why is this or why I
should be out there? I watched the ranking but.
As I said, I watch a lot the live tracking of a lot of
competition and because for me it's really important to know
really the qualities of the pilots here.
I because we, when we think about piloting, we think a lot
about analyzing conditions and stuff like this.
And but in a task like this when you are 120, it's maybe shocking
for people, but sometimes for some pilots, it's the least
important things. The wind cumulus because they
don't like they don't process it like this.
They just process the tactic. Who is with me?
The group is doing this. Is it good is not good.
But some pilots are just OK. The group is here.
I follow this. I don't need really a lot of
analyzing the condition because there is an RN in the group.
He will do the analyse because he is someone who attacks, so he
needs to analyse the condition. But some of all the pilots, they
are technically super strong, but in term of analysing
conditions, stuff like this, they don't need it to be
performed. That's quite a game sometimes.
No, one more time. I don't understand that.
In this competition, so for sure there is the condition.
So some of the profile like like myself, we have a profile of
more like attacking. Pilots figuring out what's
going. On we need to do to analyse the
condition, but some of the other pilots here, they are super
strong tactically, they are really strong technically and
they don't need much analysing the condition.
They need to analyse the pilots with them.
They're letting you do the work and.
But it's not, I'm not saying that it's better to be like this
or like this. It's a pattern which works
really well. So basically, yeah, in this
competition, analyzing the condition is not so important
for us. Some can do.
The truck and let the professionals handle it.
Yeah. And but they are really good in
lines, they are really good on choosing the speed they fly.
They are really good in in thermals.
That's not the problem. It's no problem actually.
But the strong point is the tactical announce.
OK, and if that helps that that's what I wanted to do, but
my glider was different, so let me let me use that as an excuse.
Oh man, this is such a cool conversation.
I, I don't want to deviate because talking about you and
honor is like such a, it's a never ending topic.
But do you, do you guys ever talk about that?
How long will you always have the edge or there are others
coming up and challenging your dominance?
Or how do you have that talk? Because you guys are pretty much
the top 2 in most cases. I would see a lot of people are
being like Batiste is, yeah, crazy strong.
Also there's Marcos, you see the young Spanish pilot.
Yeah, yeah, he's 1818. No way.
There is really a lot of people. Lot of young people now are
coming fast. In France, we have Tilo.
He did eights in the competition here.
Daphne, she did really great. I don't believe how she do.
What is she doing right? Because she's flying at Ian D
Ving and still landing in the goal with the first Cagle.
Yeah, Tactics you relies a lot on, on tactical stuff that we
learn them to do. So we have rules actually, it's
when we train them. Can you give me some of them
please? Yeah, we have basic rules like
we rely a lot on. No, not for the show.
Just give it to me later. So I can do that, Yeah.
No, no. In this competition, you rely a
lot on how much people you can control, you can reach with your
applied angle. And there is one rule, for
example, if someone is climbing in your Ridge, if you don't go,
you break the rule. It allows you to always secure
your positions and stuff like this.
Yeah, yeah. So, yeah, so there's a lot which
has gone on behind this good decision making.
That's interesting. That's.
Why we've we try to because tactics.
Sometimes it can with the situation, sometimes can can be
difficult to think fast. But we they are learning a lot
and with this kind of rules which are easy to apply, you can
save them some time in the decision making.
In case climbing it's in my reach.
If I don't go, I break the rules, so I go.
I think the same with the hydration.
Not every time you leave a thermal, yes.
Can apply the same. Do you have a number?
How many rules do you have and are they open for public
sharing? Yeah, it's open.
I think the best to talk about this.
Yeah, maybe you talk about. Yeah, yeah.
But we didn't talk about rules. They didn't to tell me that
there were such important rules. So man, I was telling you I
should have the whole French team on the show.
There was There should be a collective group podcast.
Now also there is some rules like this, but when you are in a
situation like you start to be in a difficult situation, the
first move you the first thing, the only thing you have to do is
to have one control on on somebody else.
You have to try to find someone to rely on again.
And it is something we try to teach early in the with the
pilots who start competition because if they rely only on
their analyzing of the conditions supply this they
bombed out really a lot more. And the idea with these simple
rules is that they increase their volume with the gaggles.
They see more situations so they'll they grow up in
experience way faster. Cool.
Yeah, No, thank you for that. OK, let's talk about skill
development a little bit because this was the topic that I
supposedly saved earlier, but I know we have to get back to the
celebrations that I'm pulling you out for. 125, How many
pilots are we here? 130 here, 130, Right?
130 pilots in the air Max. And you Max out every single
terminal comparatively. Is it because your name is Max?
What's the secret behind Think so?
Well, yeah. I think it's a lot of
experience, but also it's I think one thing which is really
important in terminaling is your ability to other 360 vision like
always find find the right informations and be able to
process it really fast. OK when I turn this guy maybe he
underneath that he's climbing a bit more than this.
Maybe I wet wait a bit more. And if I confirm, yeah, I move
super fast about it. And it's always about the vision
that there is one thing we also teach to the youngsters.
It's when you are in the situation with pilot terminaling
with you. There is something it's quite
funny rules. But if you don't have the a good
feeling, if you if you are not a pilot with like something in the
hands like feeling stuff, at least you have your eyes.
Yeah. So observe.
So you can move fast over the the pilot's climbing better.
You can move fast. And I think in this situation in
Gango, the vision is a top one, the rank list, because the
feeling is super important, but also you have to deal with the
crowd. So you can't rely 100% on it.
But you have a lot of people making the job around.
So if you don't use it well, then you don't climb good
enough. Solo terminaling going on cross
country? What's the What's the way to
improve your terminaling except practice?
Which of course will answer a lot of questions I believe.
But is there some things? Because I have been struggling
with humbling a lot especially with my left hand turns.
Like my right hand turns are so much more better.
And maybe this is just my muscles, I don't know, but I'm
just lost at this moment to be honest on where to work on.
Yeah, it's really at the peak. We we talk about a lot.
So termining 10, it's the endurance base of the pilots.
If you don't terminal well at some point you will not continue
to progress. So the idea is I have there is a
pattern pattern. We recognize also that a lot of
pilots who are terminaling really good at their really
beginning, they didn't fly a lot with Ovarium.
OK, So it's something sometimes when you didn't do that, it's
sometimes cool also when it's easy conditions and to just cut
the very to be able to process everything without it.
I don't say it's during big cross country flight because
it's but sometimes to cut it and just to rely on the sensation
isn't is important. And something we do really a lot
is especially with people wanting after to, to go to cross
countries first, you just do your training just on site.
Like you climb, you go out, you go back in the climb and you do
this. And sometimes we are training,
it's this for 3-4 hours long. Yeah, it's really repetitive
stuff I think internally because you develop the feeling.
But the feeling, it's also the thing with the wing you're
flying. It's all this kind of stuff.
So for me, sometimes it's better to just stay around, around the
places you took off and just do the job again and again.
Then then I see a lot of pilots that just decline.
They go, they land because they don't have yet the skills like
to endo any kind of thermals. And so it's better to just spend
more time in an easy spot and do it again and again.
And that's how most of the really good clients do the job.
And then that's important because when it becomes
automatic with some things, you can start analysing the
conditions. And the more you, the more
parameters you are able to process win inversions, which
altitude and everything, the better you will become for sure.
Another thing which is important is also in the piloting, you
have to try to. So in the piloting for sure it's
dependent of the thermal form and the thermal strength and and
everything. But also you have to try to add
the less parasite movements as you can parasite like, you know,
it's not the word. Maybe the less raw movement
pitch possible because why? Because you are with this when
you're piloting is too much. Yeah, not precise enough, not
accurate. Yeah, you then your sensation
are false. Because when you have a lot of
pitch, you don't know if it's the core or if it's just the
momentum. If you have too much wall, you
are not precise and it's also most of the time it also makes
your information from the very very false the disk combine.
You don't climb well because you don't place the turn when it's
the time to turn. That is so true.
Jeez, why don't I never think about this?
Yeah, having the glider, which is like, yeah, pretty stable
over the head is super important in internally.
Makes sense. Makes sense.
OK, Yeah, jeez, I wanted to. This is the last topic.
I know we're running out of time here, Second last, because the
last one is a story time for that link progression Max.
And I really want to touch upon this topic from experienced
pilot like you. I might be guilty of this
myself. And I've seen a lot of people do
this, that we progress wings way too quickly in our sport and we
almost never fly them to their lifetimes.
We are throwing away our wings much quicker than they are
finishing all their lives. Ian, A wing is a beautiful place
to start. Maybe low B is your first
preference, but the marketing from the industry is low B, mid
B, high B3 liner, C2 liner C, two liner DS.
And of course triple C is a whole different class and every
manufacturer goes out and gives out different good points about
their wings. But as a consumer who is looking
to progress, can you put emphasis on airtime?
Or how should you define your upgradation of wings without
lying to yourself? Yeah, for sure.
We a lot of pilots go really are too crazy about about the
equipment stuff because what we see as we coach people all
around the year, we see really closely the progression and
before getting to the edge, getting to the limit of the
wings where you where it's really time to change.
There is a lot of work. And also what we recognise is
when we tend to actually do the the opposite we say to the
youngster we coach that would be better to keep it.
We just try to keep it more so they are a bit upset in time,
but when they step up there is a huge progression, yeah, because
they are ready. And what I say to yeah, to
people, it's when at, I think it's yeah.
In competition, it's pretty easy to see if it's the moment of
change because you are comparing with people your skills and
stuff like this. For people who are flying solo,
it's sometimes more difficult. But when you see the performance
of the B wing, actually it's it's crazy how long you can, you
can keep it at too. So I think you can change when
you have really understood, understood every aspect of the
speed range and everything with the speed bar and you really
feel confident in any condition you're flying.
So, yeah, it's there is another problem with the sports is that
most of the people, and that's the big problem, they don't have
really outside opinion of really, really good pilots
giving them advice like coach or stuff like this.
They really rely on themselves and that's a big problem in the
sport also. So sometimes, yeah, getting
back, I think I didn't answer the question anymore.
No, I'll simplify it for you and also for our listeners, because
you know that reliability of information is why the spot cut
exists. So when do you know that you
have maxed out your wink? Is it your full stall that now
you can do any full stall? As many full stalls as you want
at any time? Or is it that 60% asymmetrics
don't scare me and I'm OK with it?
Or is it that full bar I can go even hands off full bar at
times? What are the matrix that tell
you that now you have maxed out of ink?
Yeah, I have a problem with you. You spoke about full stall and
asymmetric. The problem is when we talk
about SIV, it's not true. I and and for me it's not it can
be in a way it's a good you handle full stall, you handle a
collapse. OK.
But the most important for me is that you don't have any collapse
when you fly cross country because we speak a lot about
managing when it's when the collapse occurred.
But we don't speak about the little all the piloting before
the brake pressure, B pressure or C pressure and the little
thing that makes you really comfortable with the wing in
really specific conditions, not of the lake.
And this is when I think this is the moment when you recognise
that you are really comfortable with the win.
Maybe you are really like, yeah, you have maximised your
progression with it is when you can in most of the situation be
able to predict how it will behave.
OK, so you mean you can predict a storm is coming?
Yeah, you can predict the story. It is coming.
You can predict that. Yeah, there is this, for
example, you go, there is a climb a bit on the Lee side.
So you will be still comfortable in this, in this condition, a
bit bumpy, you will have the right piloting.
So no collapse, nothing. Because a lot of pilots, it's
funny because after the flight I had this big collapse and I'm
always like, what the fuck? What the hell?
Why did you let it up? Yeah, yeah.
And we don't talk enough about piloting before all the sketchy
thing we can encounter. OK.
Is it physically possible to prevent collapses or will they
just happen because the air is air and you can never really you
would have had collapses and you have been piloting just like any
other best? It's not a lot, actually.
Okay, yeah, it's I think yeah, of course everybody had
collapsed but really one of the thing we I think is that when it
occurs a lot, there's really a problem there's like pattern
yeah, really a big problem with the piloting because it's not
normal so then you have to analyse when you have a
collapse. So it's really important for me
to analyse like why how was the, how were the condition there?
Is there an explanation? I have misread something and
then the so it's the analysing the condition and then the
piloting. What did I feel?
Why wasn't why was unable to just stop the stuff before it
comes and but for me it's always when you add the collapse
significant one, but like the tip the significant one, it's
always take 5 minutes to understand why because it's not
yeah, it's really important. Something went wrong.
Indeed, some. And yeah, it's it's really.
Yeah, it's something showing you that something was wrong.
So yet. Reflecting.
Basically. You mean if you reflect and do
your homework properly that will prevent you from being in that?
Yes. And I think we when yeah, we
don't talk enough about analysing the conditions just
because when you are in first country, you face, of course the
turbulent conditions. Sometimes you will have to face
one. But just be aware before because
I know a lot of people, they reach the South face of these
mountains with little north and this the land we ah, so stuck in
turbulent here. I don't understand.
Ah yeah, you don't understand why.
Because you didn't do your homework.
So we have to talk more about yeah, analysing and always
trying to have an idea. Before you?
You went Yeah, before the glide, before got.
It. Yeah, I tried to anticipate.
Have you deployed ever? Yeah, I deployed 2 * 1 time was
in the final glide with the ANZ 2.
How high? Pretty low 200 between 200 to
100 meters from the ground. And but I really know why
because yet I saw the there was 1 pilot in front of me and I saw
that he entered the tubulins and I just wanted to go faster.
We not touched the beat and it ended up like with just 50%
cravat so too low to fix it. Yeah, it was the decision made
making was really fast actually I saw the wing wanted to go in
the spiral. I just checked under me and
yeah, I said throw the rest of you don't have time.
The collapse of the crowd was really big and I said there is
really poor chances that you can sort it out with only one full
stalls. So this time and another time I
was I worked as a test pilot fortune for yeah two years.
But it was, I went there sometimes in Korea and we
actually changed lines of the wing.
We did everything wrong. Actually this day we changed the
lines we put it was the prototype of the pronounza I
think and the sea lion were 20 centimetres to long like the
main sea lines. So it's.
What happens then basically? We went straight to the windy
takeoff without checking. Without ground handling.
And when I had just inflate the glider, I think, oh, everything
is a bit wrong. But I went, it just ended in the
air because I went pretty strong and actually the wing was really
fast. OK, so the angle of.
Attack. So I had the first collapse and
then yeah, the second one I throwed it in directly because I
think it's not really good. Yeah, the only times, but.
And how many hours do you have? If you have any idea Like
lifetime. I flew like between.
I have not. I tend to really write a lot,
really write my hours. If I had, I think it's now 20
years of flying. I don't I should check but 20
years it's between 6000 to 7000 hours.
Wow, that's commercial flying hours.
Yeah, because it's between. I never flew less than 250 to
300 hours and we have 24450 during, yeah, during many years.
I was going to say what an inspiring career so far because
Torstein's Tiger is that seagull, seagull, seagull.
He got an award for 100 PWC's and five PWC's in a year.
So that's 20 years of PwC. Like what a life you think he's
here for? Yeah, more yours than this.
Yeah, more than two. Decades.
Because it does. It's difficult to do 55 work of
a year. Yeah, yeah, Toss them, you said.
No, Yeah, you are insane. I think so.
Oh, Max, there is no way I can extract everything in this one
single podcast with experience like yours and the inspiration
like yours and the willingness to share, which is the most
important. I believe a lot of pilots have
the experience, but being willing to share it with the
audiences and finding the courage and to think, geez, man,
how do I even put a closing on this?
That's right. All right.
Before we close, I always ask my guests if there's one flight
that has stuck with them throughout their carrier so far
and if you can share with that or with our audiences.
You're not the only one with that dilemma.
Everybody that I asked was like, Oh my God, this is such an
open-ended question. A good to answer.
Take your time. You can edit this silence out at
the end, no worries. Yeah, I have in mind it's
sometimes it's to play. I'm thinking about when I try to
find back confidence because I really think it was, it had
everything for me. It was a 300 kilometres triangle
FI triangle flights. I did the in I think summer 23,
yeah, August I think. And it was cool because I took
my wing in the morning just and I was planning what can I do
today? Just planning the flights.
And it had really technical parts where you go through big
mountains in Germany and then in the flatlands more W from there.
And it was really special because it's not the flight you
can do every day. And yeah, it's, I really like
this 10 hours flights where you take off in the thermals.
Everything is still possible. And when you succeed to land,
just when the sun is going down, it's for me, it's always the
yeah, yeah. Just the biggest, the greatest
feeling for me. But yeah, there would be a lot
of flight. Also, the flight we did in the
French flight lands 460, the recorder, seven day French
recorder. Yeah, we landed with Bono,
Angelia and each and the first team.
It was crazy. The sun was already, yeah,
already down. We were still in the air.
So it yeah, when it comes to to this, it's most of the time it's
the big flight. Just when you know that you've
made the best out of the day. It's maybe too connected to
performance, but. Now, being one with the nature
is quite a blessing. I think parallelizers are one of
the most purest forms of aviation that we have invented.
It's yeah, it's a cool, a cool little little plane, magic Black
Flag, I like to say. It allows us to end those
things. Max, as I said, I do not know
how to put this to words, but this has been an honor, pleasure
and so much fun all at the same time, man.
Cool discussion. Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks.
Yeah. Until next time, I would say.
Yeah. It's.
It was a long time manifested. I think when I started the show
back in 2023, I was like, I had a list of people that I wanted
to get on and you were definitely one of the top 1.
So thank you, Sir. Thank you so much.
Thanks for thanks. Hey everyone, for those of you
who have listened this far, I just wanted to drop in a note of
thanks because you guys are the ones who are actually making the
difference. It means the world to me
whenever I see audience retention rates remain high all
the way to the end. And I'd like to add on by saying
that if you have liked the content that you just consumed,
do consider liking, subscribing and dropping in a rating
wherever possible. Because that is one way we can
let the algorithms of all of these streaming platforms know
that this episode is worthy of being pushed out to more pilots
in the community. So collectively, you and I can
make the sport a safer and a more fun place to be.
Well, on that note, thank you once again for joining me today.
And I'm really looking forward to connecting with you in the
next episode as well. Until then, I'm going to say
what I always say, and that is stay tuned.
Stay excited because this magic is just getting started.